tu es de plus en plus belle et c'est
vrai que capillairement
tu t'es trouvé oui mais tu t'es
longtemps cherché oui et ce soir
j'aimerais qu'on revoit toutes tes
coupes
de ta carrière voilà
tu sais qu'il faut remettre dans le
contexte
regardez regardez celle-ci regardez
voilà alors à l'époque
c'est pas nul non non
la petite ouais c'est une repousse
et les boss et les bottes
[Applaudissements]
un peu plus court on embauché
alors il y en a une que j'adore
c'est celle-là
je me suis replongé dedans
très Jennifer Aniston
il y avait du volume j'aime bien tu veux
qu'on on va reparler quand même non mais
écoute tu vois enfin j'ai eu peur je
croyais que ça allait être bien pire
quand même alors là tu vas voir
lâché
tu te cacher et enfin et enfin c'était
il y a eu ça qui était pas mal on dirait
que on dirait que tu viens d'être élu
Miss France
alors c'était pas la permanence tu vois
c'était des rajouts des trucs des
boucles
excuse-moi mais j'ai l'impression que
pour toi c'est la meilleure séquence de
ta vie
en fait ce qui pêche là c'est la Petite
France
il y aurait pas la frange tu vois il y
aurait que une espèce de chignon un peu
tombant ça y a rien à
la montagne chez sa grand-mère et sa
tante il doit donner un coup de main à
la bergerie rien de bien excitant pour
un garçon des villes comme lui mais
c'est sans compter sur sa rencontre avec
belle une chienne immense et maltraité
par son maître prêt à tout pour éviter
les injustices et protéger sa nouvelle
amie Sébastien à vivre l'été le plus fou
de sa vie c'est rigole et Sébastien
c'est un classique c'est un grand
classique là sachez-le que c'est
actuellement au cinéma c'est bel et
Sébastien nouvelle génération je crois
que tu l'as vu c'est magnifique avoir
alors les vacances arrivent faut
vraiment le savoir-faire parce que ça
rend heureux et il y a évidemment
l'aventure vous allez sans doute nous en
parler la manière dont vous tournez les
scènes avec les animaux les loups
notamment c'est extraordinaire et puis
il y a aussi tous les enjeux qui sont
dans le film les jeunes à la campagne je
ne citadins à la campagne le climat les
perturbations du climat les stations
avec la neige le rapport à la neige
l'économie il y a plein de choses
modernes et c'est franchement il y a le
mythe de Belle et Sébastien revisité
vous êtes une grand-mère extraordinaire
dedans
ne ratez pas ce film ne ratez pas ce
film surtout allez le voir allez le voir
ça me fait plaisir je crois qu'il est
très beau puis c'est un peu doux même si
enfin les animaux sont quand même aussi
mais
le tournage ou pas
non parce que j'étais tous dressés
on sait jamais
[Rires]
aideront quoi ça fait du bien et puis on
a pas le temps toujours d'aller dans la
nature et là il y a des paysages pour
s'attirer dessus franchement en ce
moment ça fait du bien
et bravo
mais bravo parce que c'est un film
magnifique et moi j'ai envie d'aller
voir le nouvel génération tu vois tu
vois un petit garçon qui est un urbain
avec les réseaux sociaux qui tout d'un
coup redécoupe des super valeurs qui va
avoir une histoire d'amitié avec un
chien qui va le qui va le sauver faut
pas que je spoile et l'intelligence du
film c'est aussi d'avoir retravaillé
l'histoire originelle parce que la
moderniser je suis d'accord dans un truc
anachronique on est vraiment dans l'air
du temps on est emprise avec direct avec
ce qui se passe exactement on parle
d'écologie mais de façon moderne et de
façon familiale
m'a complètement été réadapté donc même
si vous l'avez déjà vu dans une version
la nouvelle génération la série voilà
c'est un autre film
tu te rends compte que c'est il
s'appelle Sébastien il s'appelle belle
quoi genre on fait comme dans le film
tu vois
pas en vacances nous on sera là tout le
temps sachez-le voilà donc on sera là
vacances pas vacances on sera là bien
sûr en direct pendant toutes les
vacances de la Toussaint donc voilà et
demain on sera là bien entendu on sera
toujours là de toute façon on sera
toujours là vous allez comprendre les
vacances en juin voilà en juin enfin en
juin fin juin et Castaldi fin juillet
vous avez vu dans le film il se moque
les petits montagnards de Paris en
disant que à Paris il y a des rats
dans le 17e il m'a dit on a mangé ma
meuf et un rat
é
alors plus de 50 ans de 50 long métrage
pour notre Michel est-ce que comme dans
Belle et Sébastien tu as un caractère de
berger ce qu'on dit que c'est un
caractère difficile alors c'est quoi un
défi
je t'ai jamais vu en galère je t'ai
jamais vu de mauvaise humeur j'étais
toujours vu autant mais franchement pas
souvent
mais là ce que j'aime aussi dans le
personnage tu sais qu'elle va pas bien
parce qu'il y a trop de soucis parce que
son mari est plus là et du coup c'est
des failles à jouer et j'adore ça Michel
j'ai eu la chance de produire un film
avec elle c'est vraiment énorme c'est
vrai
parce que c'était un film
et c'est vrai que le réalisateur qui
tournait c'est claudies junior qui
tournait son premier gros film j'ai
envie de dire avec une langue Chris il
m'a dit je n'ai jamais vu ça c'est un
bonheur et tous les gens du film toutes
les tous les gens qui ont travaillé dans
le film soit les assistants les
maquilleuses tout le monde m'a dit que
Michel était en amour et qu'elle avait
été toujours de bonne humeur sur ton âge
je te l'avais énormément aidé et c'est
vraiment c'était une très très bonne
équipe non franchement mais je suis
contente parce que le film comme j'ai
jamais reçu sur le site de fou le film
il a très bien marché j'étais heureux de
produire c'était mon premier film
incroyable et c'est avec toi tu vois
donc
il est magnifique vraiment c'est de la
chatte tu commences euh
[Rires]
j'ai eu de la touchable est-ce que
est-ce que comme dans le plus beau
métier du monde que un film que j'adore
j'adore ce film est-ce que tu as déjà
été cocu hein pardon est-ce que tu as
déjà été cool
tu as jamais cramé un truc non qu'est-ce
que j'aime ce film
comme je l'aime aussi et qui est
incroyable et qu'est-ce que je l'aime ce
mec aussi j'adore les mecs qui disent
Nico
d'amour que j'aime et qui est incroyable
quoi pour moi c'est un c'est vraiment
c'est un exemple et c'est il est
mythique voilà lui il est mythique
est-ce que comme dans ton film chacun
chez soi tu as déjà fait des crasses à
ta fille
non mais en fait non ce jeu de dire
c'est que de bien élever ton enfant donc
quand vraiment tu peux lui faire
comprendre que
c'est pas tout le temps mais de temps en
temps
c'est dur mais c'est vrai que quand on
est acteur actrice quand on est et moi
je trouve que c'est on a toujours très
envie de se faire aimer même de ses
enfants
j'ai l'impression on a on a du mal à
voir de l'autorité non la jeune n'avait
quand même pas
je suis pas acteur mais j'en ai pas du
tout
une pression je te jure Michel mais une
pression oh là là est-ce que comme dans
camping 3 tu as déjà consommé des
stupéfiants
genre quoi je sais pas moi
est-ce que comme dans la crise tu
pourrais tout plaquer du jour au
lendemain
quand tout d'un coup tu évolues tu
changes etc ouais on peut on peut on
veut aller dans la vie ou tu vois sur le
son chemin donc tu te plaques ouais
ouais à l'étranger aujourd'hui
à Los Angeles pendant 5 ans je vivais
là-bas
Los Angeles
je ne suis jamais allé au Los Angeles je
n'y suis jamais allé de ma vie
je ne suis jamais allé à Los Angeles
jamais de ma vie deuxième question
avez-vous un pied-à-terre à Los Angeles
la troisième question as-tu un pied dans
ma gueule